to wrap up this lesson they want to make
sure we drive home these two main points
it is incredibly important that you're
always doing experiments and iterating
on your marketing decisions don't make
assumptions base your decisions on your
research and always time on planning the
best strategy on the first go just get
started you can iterate on your plan as
you go it's more important to measure
and improve your performance than it is
to get the absolute perfect plan down
also find the right balance between your
qualitative insights and your
quantitative data that you receive
through your experiments and user
testing you want to learn what's
happening with your marketing message to
your data and why it's happening through
your user testing this way you're going
to be able to make more informed
decisions in the future and hopefully
you're in the mindset of building
measuring and learning through marketing
experiments on an ongoing basis now we
really want to congratulate you on
completing this course we wish you the
best of luck in your future endeavors
come back and share your awesome apps
with us when you have them bye